we are here with Nick sitar of the
earthquake engineering research center
we want to know where in this incredible
facility it's huge it's beautiful what
actually happens here
well this facility is operated by the
University of California to provide
researchers with access to major testing
equipment and we have a shaking table
facility and then we have a hybrid
simulation facility which is funded by
the national sound science foundation
what happens in an earthquake
is relatively simple in the sense that
the ground moves and the building moves
with the ground and because the building
has a certain amount of mass that mass
the inertia of the building then
produces forces within the building and
it's those forces that then can cause
failures so what we have to do is design
the building to move in such a way that
either doesn't couple with the ground
motion or it can resist the forces that
are generated there are several
different technologies that that are
used base isolation as it is called to
isolate the building from the ground
motion is one one approach that's being
used and it's being used more and more
not just for buildings but also for
bridges and basically like shock
absorbers in a car they allow the
building to remain relatively stationary
relative to the ground
one of the things that the most people
don't immediately think about is once
you put a building on base isolation the
building is going to move relative to
the ground and so now you have to
provide space between the building and
surrounding ground so a building like
that would be surrounded by kind of a
moat if you want to think about it that
way that provides the separation between
the rest of the ground and the building
foundation now what it means is that all
the utilities and all the connections to
the building have to be flexible so that
they can accommodate all that motion one
of the basic tools that we use in our
laboratory is the shaking table which is
just a large in our case concrete
concrete platform it's 20 by 20 feet and
it can move in three directions and we
apply actual ground motions
during earthquakes but there are things
that you don't see for example the way
bracing is applied even in wood
structures the way reinforcement is
placed in concrete the type of concrete
that's used so there are a lot of other
things that may not be all that visible
which all represent technological
changes so what this huge machine behind
us what kind of experiments are done on
that well this is a four million pound
compression machine that was actually
built in 1930s to test large building
components and we have incorporated it
into our hybrid simulation laboratory to
be able to simulate full building loans
on things like columns in buildings we
do a lot of computer modeling in fact a
lot of what we do applies directly to
computer simulation but because a lot of
these building a lot of these structures
are very large and they're unique in
their shape and in their dimensions we
cannot quite simulate everything
directly and therefore we need to have
some experimental data to back up the
simulations or to allow us to do the
simulations so so what do you do if
you're a typical worker in a cubicle and
in a in an office space where the
doorframe is very far away well it turns
out that the acoustic ceilings and the
lights above you are probably the the
biggest danger to you so diving on the
old adage about diving under your desk
is still the best advice that can be
given